Boa noite minhas amigas meus amigos para
mais uma live é um prazer est aqui com
vocês vocês provavelmente vão escutar um
eco na minha voz porque eu tô aqui na
sala do consultório de São Paulo que eu
tô essa semana porque nós estamos
mudando para Um Novo Endereço na mesma
rua da minha casa então me perdoe se
vocês ouvirem
Eco Mas é porque hoje eu tô fazendo Live
para vocês aqui do consultório que eu tô
deixando que tá ficando com menos móveis
menos equipamento então gera esse Eco e
a Geralmente eu faço a Live com vocês de
casa hoje é uma exceção Boa Noite Marta
Boa noite Carlos Então como já foi
combinado previamente eu vou começar a
Live de hoje respondendo às perguntas do
documento e só depois eu vou fazer
exposição hoje eu queria fazer uma coisa
um pouquinho diferente eu queria fazer
para vocês uma mini aula sobre a
Ivete Não vou falar o nome real do
medicamento por razões que vocês já
sabem então eu peço para vocês também
não comentarem o nome real vamos chamar
de Ivete tá eu assisti uma aula da Luci
care uma aula de 1 hora e meia de
douração muito técnica e eu tirei dessa
aula o bizu né O que que seria
interessante para vocês vocês não
ficarem ouvindo sopa de letrin de
bioquímica que é muito chato às vezes né
boa noite também tam miquinha bem Vamos
às
perguntas primeira pergunta deixa eu
aumentar aqui o tamanho da tela
Ah tá seria esse layout aqui mesmo bem
deixa eu aumentar o tamanho
da creio que assim tá fácil de ler
acho que melhor assim
né deixar esse layout aqui
assim primeira
pergunta
da Fernanda Chaves Boa noite tenho 46
anos e artrose nos dois joelhos
decorrente do sobrepeso mas agora mal
estou andando devido a dor por favor
gostaria de saber se tem alguma fórmula
para ajudar a melhorar grande abraço sim
tem fórmulas para ajudar a melhorar mas
antes eu queria comentar algumas coisas
a respeito do que você tá comentando
sobre peso Eu lamento que esteja
passando por esse momento difícil devido
à artrose mas é importante saber que a
artrose ela tá muito ligada ao aumento
de peso o sobrepeso é um fator de risco
muito significativo para desenvolvimento
de artroses em geral especialmente em
joelho porque aumenta a carga mecânica
então para melhorar isso daí é muito
importante você abordar o sobrepeso
porque a perda de peso vai reduzir a
pressão sobre os joelhos vai aliviar a
dor e melhorar a capacidade funcional
Então siga as orientações do canal faça
uma dieta ketoflex tem muito material
sobre isso no canal do
YouTube é muito importante fazer uma
atividade física regular também começa
com caminhada se você não consir fazer
caminhada faz hidroginástica faz
natação faça alongamentos faça
exercícios de fortalecimento muscular a
própria musculação ou então pilates isso
vai ajudar aliviar dor vai ajudar a
melhorar a mobilidade então é importante
você ter o complimento profissional pode
ser um fisioterapeuta um profissional de
educação física para criar um plano de
exercício adequado é melhor que até que
seja um pilates com fisioterapeuta para
sem é seguro Então existe também a
possibilidade de você procur um
ortopedista para fazer a visco
suplementação que envolve injetar ácido
hialurônico nas articulações
então é muito importante também você
tirar os alimentos processados os
alimentos industrializados o açúcar as
farinhas Ok faça uma dieta mais rica em
vegetais coloridos que crescem acima do
solo como uma gorduras saudáveis abacate
nozes castanhas
Semente de abóbora semente de gelim
semente de girassol azeite de oliva e
corte os carboidratos refinados isso vai
ajudar muito a desinflamar suplementos
Você tem o C2 que é o colágeno
hidrolizado Tipo dois você tem o dmso
que eu falei em live que foi uma das
lives mais bem sucedidas dos últimos
meses falei do msm também nessa Live
então dmso msm curcumina bzu serrata
extrato de gengibre extrato de canela de
velho extrato de garra de diabo o pea
que é o palmitoil etanolamina também
muito interessante ord de copaíba o
próprio canabidiol os produtos
canabinoides Ok cheque no documento que
você tem acesso o link tá lá no YouTube
para você ler sobre antiinflamatórios
naturais tem lá documentos sobre isso
para você poder estudar sobre esses
antiinflamatórios que eu tô mencionando
brevemente aqui o que Ok vamos pra
próxima pergunta
ol isso aqui não é Apertei o botão
errado da Mata perz a betaína base
trimetilglicina pode ser usado por via
sublingual sim pode não terium problema
de você colocar debaixo da língua onde
será absorvida diretamente pela mucosa
né Isso pode até aumentar a
biodisponibilidade do suplemento porém
existe uma limitação física de volume
você não consegue colocar por exemplo
200 300 400 mg so lingual fica muito
difícil então Em algumas situações é
importante você usar doses mais altas
Isso vai ser uma coisa
individualizada por causa do efeito
antiinflamatório por causa do efeito de
modulação do sistema imun por causa do
efeito de
detox o aumento de o efeito de aumento
da glutationa então para isso ser viável
sublingual não vai suficiente Então vai
ter situações que o sublingual poderá
ser utilizado mas nesse caso se for o
volume mais alto não vai ser possível né
E qual é a função da trimetilglicina ele
vai desempenhar um papel muito
importante na metilação do DNA no
controle da homocisteína reduzindo os
níveis dessa aminoácido que tá ligado a
doenças cardiovasculares doenças
neurodegenerativas e também
osteoporose e também tá ligado a
problemas aí de do doenças ginecológicas
também tá ligado a problemas
psiquiátricos próxima
pergunta você acha que usar tampões
auriculares de silicone para bafar ruído
quando dormir pode piorar o zumbido e
prejudicar a audição não acredito que
não porque os tampões auriculares são
utilizado para quê ruído como você mesmo
tá dizendo e podem ser utilizados
durante o sono
isso ajuda a pessoa ter um sono mais
tranquilo se ela mora num ambiente muito
barulhento os vizinhos fazem festa fazem
confusão
e não no meu entendimento não causaria
danos à audição usar o tampão se foi de
boa qualidade se utilizado corretamente
se ele foi higienizado de forma
regular o que vai atrapalhar muito ao
sua audição e causar zumbido é o próprio
ruído né o zumbido a principal causa do
zumbido tinidos é exposição a ridos
altos mas pode ser também por infecções
ou problemas auditivos então o zumbido
vai piorar muito mais se você ficar
exposto ao ruído do que você utilizar o
tampão Ficou claro isso existe vários
tipos de tampões os de silicone É um
tipo tem os de espuma também e
Geralmente os de espuma são mais
eficientes na redução do ruído Ok então
é meio que o contrário que você tá
colocando
aí próxima
pergunta da Marilda LDL em homens menor
que 26 é considerado
hipobetalipoproteinemia
Quais sintomas são avaliados para
confirmar o distúrbio como é tratado em
paciente que não consegue comer gordura
bem essa é uma situação bem Rara Eu
particularmente nunca peguei pacientes
com hipet lip emia e é caracterizado por
níveis muito baixos de lipoproteínas de
baixa densidade ou níveis muito baixos
de LDL no sangue então antes de falar
que é isso é bom confirmar para ver se
não é erro de laboratório porque isso é
raro tá eu mesmo 27 anos que eu tenho de
carreira eu nunca vi então embora a
maioria das pessoas se preocupe com os
níveis de LDL postarem altos né que
estariam Associados aí a
ateroesclerose infarto AVC isquêmico
níveis muito baixo também é bem
problemático tá então essa condição
genética ela afeta a produção ou
transporte de lipoproteínas no
corpo nós sabemos que a lipoproteína que
que é é um navio que carrega moléculas
de gordura e também vitaminas
lipossolúveis tá então a lipoproteína
por exemplo apolipoproteína A1 ap
apolipoproteína B são moléculas que são
como se fosse navios que carregam
gorduras e outras substâncias
correlacionadas a gorduras então o LDL é
conhecido como se fosse o colesterol
ruim a fração proteica do LDL é
apolipoproteína b né como eu falei esse
navio que carrega gordura e porém o l
tem função no organismo Ele vai levar o
colesterol e essas vitaminas
lipossolúveis para os tecidos ele vai
levar também de volta
eh é a maneira que o fígado tem de
mandar essas gorduras para os tecidos
periféricos então níveis muito baixos de
LDL vão levar problemas de saúde
problemas de deficiência nutricional
deficiência de vitamina lipossolúvel né
então você vai ter dificuldade em
processar as vitaminas ade K ah que são
as vitaminas lipossolúveis você vai ter
dificuldade de levar gordura pra parede
da célula que é importante para fazer a
parede celular você vai ter dificuldade
de de formar B que é feito também com
gordura uma série de problemas
importantes aí você vai ter fraqueza
muscular problem de visão doenças
neurológicas pode ter diarreia dor
abdominal perda de peso devido a
absorção de gorduras e problemas
neurológicos por conta da do fato que 60
a 70% do cérebro é feito de gordura
Então você vai ter fraqueza muscular
problemas de coordenação casos graves
Você pode até ter uma doença
neurodegenerativa como se fosse um
Alzheimer Ok então o tratamento da
hipobetalipoproteinemia
tem que ser reposição de gordura
reposição de vitaminas lipossolúveis
e nessa posição tomar um especial
Cuidado para usar a gordura de faa
absorção como é o caso
e por exemplo do Óleo de coco ou do TCM
né ou
MCT então para pacientes que não
consegue comer gordura a minha dica é
usar o TCM que é uma fonte de gordura aí
de alta absorção e que não precisa ser
ingerida em grandes quantidades
Marilda Quais são os valores de
referência ideais para HDL em
homens o HDL ideal para homens está na
faixa entre 50 e 60 ok no mínimo tem que
tá 40 então tente chegar nessa faixa
entre 50 60 mas se você não conseguir
pelo menos 40 de HDL mulheres e a gente
tem que deixar o verdade mais alto Ainda
por volta de 50 a
70 D Ana Paula está na Live viu pessoal
Caso vocês queiram interagir com ela ela
tá colocando até uma situação aqui da
higiene dos tampões que eu comentei
aqui
eh Marilda Qual o valor ideal para apo
lip proteína B dividido por apo A1 em
homens e mulheres e sendo maior ou menor
que o ideal o que deve significar bem
não existe menor que o ideal existe o
ideal e o alto tá o risco mais baixo é
abaixo de 0,6 Ok Isso é o ideal para
todo mundo o risco médio entre 0,6 e
0,8 e o risco mais alto é acima de 0,8
Ok então esse marcador aí dessa continha
né é um o índice ap B bar A1 é
importante marcador para avaliar o risco
cardiovascular porque ele reflete o
balanço né o equilíbrio entre as
partículas aterogênicas que é as
partículas do LDL ap b e as anti
aterogênicas seria ap A1 Então esse
índice é considerado superior a
avaliação isolada do LDL colesterol do
HDL colesterol Ok então eu uso bastante
esse índice quando eu ten em dúvidas aí
quando eu tenho um caso de pacientes por
exemplo que tem LDL meio alto e o
trigliceres não acompanha também
junto então se o índice for maior que 08
tem que baixar o nível do LDL D ap
lipoproteína B porque isso indica um
aumento de risco cardiovascular
geralmente essas pessoas que têm esse
problema também T trigliceridos
altos então nosso objetivo sempre deixar
nessa faixa abaixo 0,6 dessa relação Ok
E para isso tem várias estratégias você
pode usar o extrato da Bergamota que é o
Asgard você pode usar o exen nicotinato
de inositol você pode utilizar o
próprio estatinas aí em doses mais
baixas é uma estratégia completamente
válida na na minha
experiência Você pode usar também os
tocotrienois do ucum também ajudam a
fazer esse equilíbrio você pode utilizar
a pantetina que é um derivado da
vitamina B5 você pode utilizar também
algumas fibras que podem ajudar a
controlar isso então tem várias
estratégias aí para isso
tá Marilda T3 abaixo de 80 é considerado
hipotiroidismo sim é considerado só que
eu na minha prática viu Marilda eu
valorizo muito mais o T3 livro e o T4
livro do que o T3 total e t4 total vocês
sabem que
hipotiroidismo é uma situação é uma
condição em que a glândula tireóide não
produz hormônios tiroidianos de forma
suficiente e vai afetar o metabolismo do
corpo inteiro né Principalmente a
formação de calor e ativação de outros
hormônios no entanto é importante
considerar que você faça exames também
de TSH de T4 Liv e T3 Liv para chegar a
uma conclusão final sobre isso ok isso
tem que ser individualizado com o médico
no consultório Você sabem muito bem que
a causa mais comum de hipotiroidismo é
doença de rimoto ou tiroidite rachim
noto
e a segunda causa mais comum é pós
cirurgia ou pós tratamentos aí para
nódulos de tireoide que pode ser com
iodoterapia
radioativa
também próxima pergunta Marta Dr Lair
disse em vídeo que a espirulina tem uma
pseud vitamina B2 que neutraliza a ved
animal e portanto é prejudicial concorda
com ele concorda Existe uma substância
na espirulina chamada pseud vitamina B12
também conhecida como
adenin adenin cobamamida esse nome
esquisito aí adenin cobam ela é
metabolicamente inativa em
humanos infelizmente espirulina é rica
nesse composto Então tem que tomar
cuidado com a espirulina não deve tomar
continuamente e Estudos mostram que
cerca de 83% da B12 da espirulina é
nessa forma de pseudo B12 Adenil camida
e apenas 17% é vitamina B12
ativa então é importante vocês tomarem
cuidado e não exagerar na espirulina e
se tiver que usar espirulina por um
tempo mais prolongado por algum motivo
que o médico prescreveu ter que utilizar
a mecobalamina eh paralelamente para
evitar esses problemas aí da pseudo
B12 e pessoas que são veganas e
vegetarianas tem que tomar especial
cuidado porque elas tendem a usar mais
espirulina que a população em geral
Então tem que ficar muito atentas e
utilizar a reposição de metilcobalamina
ou hidróxico alamina para
contrabalançar
a 5 anos você postou um vídeo com o
título top 15 suplementos para prevenir
o câncer de próstata
se um jovem adulto consumi os
suplementos pensionados a partir de
agora e permanecer consumindo para
sempre ele terá boas Chan de prevenir o
câncer próstata boas Chan terá Tá certo
essa pergunta do Eliseu pel pelo estilo
da pergunta eu sabia que era ele
eh sim vai ter boas chances mas mais
importante que os suplementos é você ter
bons hábitos de vida né que a dieta
equilibrada é o jejum intermitente
atividade física eh alimentação rica em
alimentos não processados
industrializados né sono adequado
gerenciamento do estresse adequado
evitar o tabagismo etilismo Ok então não
fique confiando só em suplemento pode
utilizar mas não existe nada na vida que
é garantido você sabe disso então faça
com responsabilidade sem exageros e
também cuide do seu estilo de vida
120 anos acho bem ambicioso né mas não
acho que impossível não se a
medicina tiver um Boom aí com a
inteligência artificial nos próximos 10
a 15 anos que não acho impossível pode
ser viável você viver até 120
anos mas acho que aí vai ter que ter
bastante intervenção não só usar
suplemento bem vamos para as perguntas
ao vivo
[Música]
eh exames de rotina aqui Eliseu são os
exames que se pede no consultório tá que
é função renal função hepática
hemograma verificar se a pessoa tem
doença autoimune verificar os marcadores
inflamatórios tá é isso que eu quis
dizer que um exame de rotina
a B2 é muito segura não é tóxica viu
Eliseu porém se você tá já com nível de
Sangue Bom de vitamina B12 por volta de
1000 não justifica você ficar mantendo a
suplementação ou então você deve baixar
bastante a dose
suplemento essa pergunta é para as
pessoas em geral que estão acompanhando
a Live não para mim a me parece isso Boa
noite Elane boa noite nild boa noite
Estela
Mares Boa noite Dr an Paulo
Rodrigues Ana Paula dando umas dicas
aí olha aí que eu não falei a glicina
tem sabor
amargo vai atrapalhar o uso
sublingual aqui eu já comentei
isso bom senso importante bom senso
né Depende da Necessidade Marta
né uma colher de café Rasa vai
ter por volta de 1 a 2 g aí pode ser uma
dose totalmente
n suficiente aí para várias situações aí
dor atrás do joelho quando Dobra a perna
deixa ela responder
aí pronto ela
respondeu qual é a cor da coenzima q10
um médico disse que a coenzima
verdadeira tem cor
alaranjada sim procede sim procede sim
na verdade você não vai isolar com
enzima que é 10 dos outros elementos que
ela ela geralmente ela é associada ela é
associada com algumas gorduras saudáveis
geralmente ela tá com um pouquinho de
ômega3 então ela vai ter essa cor sim
tá Não nunca se Analisa exame
isoladamente Marilda é o conjunto
tá o soluo frequente após as
refeições pode indicar que você tá com
uma disfagia com alguma dificuldade de
engolir tem que ser analisado isso aí
por um autorino ou por
neurologista Então você tá engolindo
bastante ar e ou pode ser uma disfagia
então Eh procura mastigar mais devagar a
comida primeiro antes de fazer qualquer
outra coisa matica de bastante a comida
come devagar e não beba líquidos nas
refeições se isso não resolver você
procura uma Torina
o limite para TGP por volta de 30 tem
laboratório que coloca essa faixa 30 32
tá Se tiver acima disso pode geralmente
é estresse no fígado Ok a Live
caiu tem certeza que a Live
caiu pessoal me dá um feedback aí porque
para mim tá tudo normal aqui tá
o site da bos
interessante
aa confirmando
aí mais uma informação aí que pode ser
Branco se for
micronizado Max é uma coisa queed
supostamente top mas é cara tá eu não
tenho Total convicção que ela é superior
à
demais eu tô usando a garrafinha eh na
verdade eu não tô usando o gerador
inalado não tô usando a garrafinha eu
tenho também
o os como é que fala
osc hora de falar aí o negócio põe na
água mas eu não usei ainda o negócio põe
na
água Sim pode ser sintoma de tumor de
tórax ve uma compressão de um nervo
toráxico pode provocar também soluço
obrigado por ter falado que não
[Música]
caiu obrigado pelo feedback de vocês
aí Bem pessoal vamos então partir pro
pra miniaula que eu separei para vocês
aqui baseado no material da D Lu
tá deixa eu mudar a
tela deixa ver se eu consigo fazer aqui
uma coisa jogar isso para
cá vai ficar mais fácil deixa eu desv
outra tela
aqui
[Música]
compartilhar deixa eu ver como é que tá
isso
aqui que eu vou mudar para esse layout
de novo aqui pera aí esse aqui ou esse
aqui ah vou deixar nesse layout
aqui deixa aumentar a dose aumentar
tamanho
aqui bem pessoal e eu vou falar um
pouquinho sobre Ivete eu sei que tá
escrito aí o nome real eu não sei até
que ponto isso vai ser problema pro
Canal
não mas vamos lá a Ivete pessoal ela tem
sido alvo de muitas investigações nos
últimos anos né nós sabemos que é o
Originalmente um remédio para vermes né
E tem sido utilizado amplamente desde a
década de 80 Então já tem bastante tempo
de experiência com a Ivete foi
desenvolvida Originalmente para tratar
infecções
parasitárias em animais depois passou a
ser utilizada em humanos em alguns
países ela nunca foi aprovada para uso
humano tá isso é uma coisa que eu
gostaria que vocês tivessem essa
informação a sua descoberta e aplicação
Inicial renderam aos desenvolvedores o
prêmio Nobel de fisiologia e medicina em
2015 então foi um impacto muito
significativo na saúde pública durante
os os anos para trás aí do evento de
saúde que vocês sabem ela ganhou
bastante
destaque com a possível opção
terapêutica porém foi muito contestado
você sabe que viveram isso então
pesquisadores e médicos começaram a
investigar o seu potencial antiviral
especialmente contra aquele vírus que
nós sabemos qual que é né estudos
preliminares sugeriram que a Ivete
poderia inibir a replicação viral
reduzir inflamação levando uma série de
ensaios clínicos e debates sobre sua
eficácia e segurança no contexto de
saúde que vocês sabem qual que é
porém além do seu uso
tradicional como antiparasitário a Ivete
foi redescoberta para Outras aplicações
foi estudada em inv vitro e inv vivo eu
vou falar mais sobre isso daqui a pouco
pesquisas recentes indicam que ela pode
ter propriedades
anticancerígenas
antiinflamatórias isso amplia o seu
potencial terapêutico Então essas
descobertas abriram
novas frentes de estudo explorando a
Ivete como ela poderia ser integrada em
tratamentos combinados para diversas
condições desde infecções virais até
cânceres então a popularidade da iet nos
últimos anos trouxe à tona a importância
de mais pesquisas para confirmar os seus
benefícios
e se nós conseguimos estabelecer
diretrizes Claras para seu uso né Não
sei se isso vai chegar
a termo por causa da perseguição né
embora alguns estudos tenham mostrado em
resultados promissores a comunidade
científica continua a investigar para
garantir que seu uso seja seguro e
eficaz então tem vários mecanismos de
ação um dos principais
mecanismos é a
inibição da entrada do vírus na célula
Então ela bloqueia a conexão do vírus
com o
receptor ali O o aquele receptor
importante o ace2 Né o ek2 ace2 em
inglês ek2 em português ela não vai
deixar que a proteína Spike se ligue a
esse receptor na superfície das células
humanas e bloqueia assim a infecção
Inicial Além disso ela vai interferir na
otação
nuclear das proteínas virais que é
essencial paraa
replicação do
vírus então tem várias mecanização então
ao ocupar o espaço que seria utilizado
pelas proteínas virais para entrar no
núcleo a Ivete vai interromper a
replicação e a montagem do vírus outro
aspecto crucial da ação da Ivete é a sua
capacidade de suprimir proteínas tóxicas
induzidas pelo vírus vou falar que a
apenas alguns nomes tem vários outros tá
essas proteínas são conhecidas como 3cl
pro
npr elas são responsáveis pela ativação
de várias partes do vírus que causam
danos ao organismo então inverte vai se
ligar essas proteínas inibindo a função
e prevenindo a liberação de
poliproteínas virais
tóxicas lembrando pessoal que são
estudos inv vitro in viiv não tem
estudos clínicos ainda tá então tudo que
eu tô falando aqui tem que ser levado
muito em consideração que a gente não
tem estudos clínicos eu vou falar do
estudo lá de Itajaí mas estudo Itajaí
foi um estudo observacional não foi um
estudo que tenha sido feito para avaliar
protocolo de
tratamento a também desempenha um papel
significativo na regulação de vias
inflamat
como a stat
3 e a interoc 6 então infecção pelo
vírus lá pode desencadear uma tempestade
de citocinas uma resposta inflamatória
exagerada que pode ser Fatal se viveram
isso né naqueles anos atrás Então ivet
vai inibir essa proteína stat 3 que é
uma proteína Central na Cascata
inflamatória vai suprir a produção de 6
que é uma cocina altamente inflamatória
e ao fazer isso a ivet vai ajudar a
controlar a resposta inflamatória do
corpo e reduzir a gravidade de sintomas
prevenindo complicações graves como a
síndrome do desconforto respiratória Se
bem que hoje tá muito raro ver isso mas
historicamente aí durante os anos atrás
Vocês tiveram momentos que isso foi
muito
importante então esses múltiplos
mecanismos de ação tornaram Ivete uma
droga versátil potencialmente eficaz no
tratamento do vírus no entanto é
importante continuar as pesquisas porque
não tem pesquisas Claras clínicas para
confirmar esses
benefícios vamos falar sobre os estudos
de Itajaí agora né os estudos realizados
em Itajaí são alguns dos mais
abrangentes detalhados né Foi um n muito
grande mais de 200.000 pessoas avaliadas
que avaliou a eficácia da ivet no
tratamento mas principalmente na
prevenção o primeiro estudo foi
publicado em janeiro de 2022 analisou a
profilaxia com ivet e um população de
mais de 150.000 pessoas e os resultados
mostraram uma redução significativa nas
taxas de infecção hospitalização e
mortalidade então de maneira mais
específica teve uma redução de 44% na
taxa
de
infecção 56% na hospitalização e 68 na
mortalidade esses dados foram obtidos
através de uma análise estatística
robusta utilizando o método de propen
score matching que par indivíduos
semelhantes com e sem tratamento para
garantir a validade de resultados o
segundo estudo do Itajaí foi publicado
em agosto de
2022 ele focou na relação dose resposta
Esse estudo incluiu 88.000 pacientes
revelou que o uso regular da ivet estava
associado a uma redução ainda maior das
taxas de hospitalização e mortalidade
que o uso irregular então usuários
regulares de Vet não foram
hospitalizados e apresentaram uma
redução de
92% na mortalidade em comparação com os
não usuários e mesmo uso irregular da
ivet mostrou benefícios significativos
uma redução de 37% na mortalidade em
comparação com aqueles que não usaram Ok
e comparando com outras cidades que não
utilizaram Ivete teve um reforço ainda
maior desses achados então comparações
entre Itajaí e outras cidades foram as
seguintes enquanto Itajaí Teve um
aumento de apenas 23% nos casos aí eu tô
falando da incidência não tô falando nem
da moralidade da incidência teve um
aento de 23% dos casos da doença né de
Julho a novembro de 2020 a cidade de
laes que não adotou o uso da ivet vi um
aumento de 1000% 104% no mesmo período
então esses dados sugerem que a ivet
pode ter desempenhado o papel crucial na
contenção da pandemia Ok então
destacando a necessidade de mais estudos
eh para confirmar esse resultados mas
vocês vejam a disparidade dos números
Então esse estudos fornecem evidências
promissores sobre a eficácia da ivet mas
é importante lembrar que a comunidade
científica ainda não aceita isso ainda
está investigando Porque os estudos
clínicos são muito poucos ainda para
garantir a segurança e eficácia tem
vários estudos na época da nós estamos
falando mais sobre isso eu tinha
levantado mais de 40 estudos mas eram
estudos pequenos tá então esse que é o
problema a respeito da parte clínica
então a continuidade das pesquisas é
muito importante para estabelecer
diretrizes Claras e baseadas em
evidências para que a comunidade de modo
geral aceite esses dados e garantindo
que a gente possa utilizar sem viés
político Ok vamos falar um pouquinho da
ação
anticancerígena recentemente ela foi
estudada Então por seu potencial no
tratamento diversos tipos de câncer e
pesquisas indicam que ela pode inibir a
proliferação de células tumorais e
reduzir a metástase tornando-se uma
aliada promissora no ramo da Oncologia
entre os tipos de câncer que a invete
mostrou efeitos positivos estão a
leucemia o câncer de mama o de ovário o
melanoma e muitos outros então foram 17
tipos de câncer nos quais a Ivete
mostrou a atividade anticancerígena E aí
com são os mecanismos né entre elas tá a
regulação de vias de sinalização celular
como a kinase pac um tá presente em 70%
dos cânceres então a Ivete inibe essa
enzima e impede a comunicação entre
células tumorais e promove a morte
programada dessas células que é a
apoptose e também a piropos e também
autofagia então além disso a Ivete é
capaz de inibir células as tronc
tumorais que são responsáveis pela
Regeneração e manutenção do tumor algo
que muitas terapias convencionais não
conseguem
fazer outro aspecto importante é a
capacidade da Ivete de aumentar a
sensibilidade das células cancerígenas a
químio e reduzir a resistência a
múltiplas drogas então isso significa
que quando usado em combinação com
outras terapias antitumorais a Ivete
pode potencializar os efeitos desses
tratamentos e diminuir os efeitos
adversos essa cominação poderia ser
especialmente benéfica para pacientes
que já desenvolveram resistência a
certos medicamentos quimioterápicos
Então essas descobertas vão abrir novas
possibilidades pro uso dessa medicação
na Oncologia destacando a necessidade
mais estudos para confirmar esses
efeitos e também para ter uma aceitação
maior da comunidade
científica Então tá se mostrando uma
versatilidade muito grande da ivet como
uma droga m alvos e tem um potencial
terapêutico importante não apenas contra
infecções parasitárias e virais mas
também no combate do Câncer Ok tem
também ação
antidiabética é muito interessante por
esse lado também ok
Pessoal lembrando tá Nunca faça uso da
ived sem um acompanhamento por o médico
por um profissional de saúde a
automedicação pode levar a muitos
problemas a efeitos adversos
complicações que podem ser totalmente
desnecessárias tem relatos raros aí de
insuficiência hepática então o certo
seria o profissional de saúde tá
acompanhando isso com muita cautela e tá
apresentando o termo de consentimento
informado pro paciente explicando que
tem outras alternativas para as doenças
que a Ivete Poderia ajudar mas se ele
tiver disposto a assinar o termo de
consentimento e também começar a
escalonar a dose para minimizar a
possibilidade de qualquer efeito mais
grave como insuficiência hepática ou
pancreática que são raríssimas mas que
são Teoricamente possíveis
tá muito bem
isso Ana Paula tá falando uma coisa
importante aqui tá na verdade não vamos
conseguir compartilhar porque tá no
grupo tá no na parte fechada do YouTube
mas mesmo assim eu peço para vocês não
compartilharem esse conteúdo
Tá sim poderá causar efeitos eh
colaterais se foi utilizado por muito
tempo eu acho improvável mas tem que ser
é muito cauteloso elizu PR acontecer
qualquer problema isso vai ser um um
escândalo
Ok na aula da Dora Lucia k ela colocou
que a metabolização hepática da Ivete é
muito pequena mas eu fiz uma varredura
na internet e tem sim tá muitos estudos
falando de problemas hepáticos que podem
ser
exagerados eu acho também que foram em
situações muito específicas pontuais com
associações da ivet com outras
substâncias que levaram a septico Então
eu acho que foi exagerado esse efeito
mas uma percepção minha existe
literatura falando disso a gente não
pode ignorar isso tem que ser muito
cauteloso porque vocês sabem que certas
coisas chamam muito mais atenção do que
outras né a gente tem que ter muito
cautela com isso daí
a maioria dos eu minos tá e também ela
ela não pega que eu sabe por exemplo
geard tá geard ela não pega mas ela pega
a maioria dos elos tá essa informação
exata de todos a quantidade para mim ele
pega 90% dosos Tá mas eu posso ver ficar
isso com
mais
propriedade e tá falando com vocês em
outros momentos oportunos mais perguntas
pessoal que que vocês acharam da mini
aula que eu dei aí gostaram não gostaram
eu tentei ir bem direto ao
ponto mas eu aceito o críticas aí
construtivas
H aig qu tá fazendo com comentário aqui
obrigado
tiquinha sim continua
nild Obrigado
Marta eu tô dando uma olhada
aqui os vermes mais estudados em relação
a Ivete é stroid est corales onc cerca
que é um que pega né que é comum lá na
África no Brasil não tem com cercose
filariose né que é elefantiase
ascaridiase que é lombriga a escabiose
que é Sana e a pediculose que é o piolho
Tá mas eu pode ser que tenha algum verme
aqui que eu não abordei que a Ivete pega
também
mais perguntas
pessoal Ah o pessoal tá se manifestando
aqui obrigado Eliseu Obrigado Estela
Obrigado
Marta bem direto ao ponto né isso quis
fazer para vocês
aí marca de suplemento de gengibre de
cabeça aqui não tô lembrando de não o
doctors first tem Ana Paula
eh suo de gengibre Ana Paula ficou
especialista em doctors first você tá
acompanhando a Live
Ainda bem vamos ver se ela responde de
cabeça não lembro não
viu como é que tá o áudio tá dando muito
Eco vocês podem me responder sobre isso
el dizendo que não tem gengibre no
Doctor
first Eu também não tenho um
conhecimento muito abrangente do Doctor
first
Não
obrigado bem pesso acho vou encerrar né
estamos 45
minutos tivemos menos perguntas essa
semana também falando que o áudio está
bom
obrigado obrigado também a elía pelo
feedback Então vou encerrar tá pessoal
Muito obrigado pela presença de vocês
Nós não vemos na semana que vem um beijo
um abraço e vocês são Fera